the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right a little slow getting started
today better get going
what we're going to talk about today is
a technique a guy's done okay thanks
we're going to talk about it today is a
technique known as modal analysis and
it's a way of analyzing things that
vibrate essentially thinking about the
one mode at a time though you might not
make a lot of use of the actual
calculations doing the math throughout
your careers I think if you understand
it conceptually it'll help you just have
a better understanding of what vibration
is all about just give you some insight
to it that you otherwise wouldn't have
the basic concept is that you can model
just about any structural vibration as
the summation of the individual
contributions of each what we call
natural mode so what we mean by that is
let's start by thinking actually say
that this applies to both continuous
systems like vibrating strings or beams
or buildings as it does to finite degree
of freedom rigid body systems we've been
we haven't talked about continuous
systems I'll do a lecture on it as the
last lecture of the term it's kind of an
enrichment sort of lecture but
everything I say about finite degree of
freedom systems can be extended to
continuous systems but we'll since we've
been studying rigid bodies and systems
with finite numbers of degrees of
freedom I'll explain I'll go through
this analysis in the context of rigid
body finite degree freedom systems so in
general we can write the equations of
motion for finite degree freedom systems
as a mass matrix and to keep they're
kind of writing down I'm just going to
underline
matrices and a squiggle under vectors so
we have them in general we can write the
equations of motion so mass matrix times
a an acceleration vector plus a damping
matrix times the velocity vector
stiffness matrix times a displacement
vector all equal to some external vector
of excitations now I'm writing these as
if these are translations but you know
like from doing the cart the pendulum on
the current problem that the equations
of motion might involve rotations and
displacements and we let them you know
they mix together here however they fall
out but it just to write them
symbolically I'm just going to call them
all refer to all of those coordinates at
with an X vector okay now the basic
premise of modal analysis is a thing
called the modal expansion theorem it's
basically the assertion that you can
represent any motion set of vectors I'll
write them kind of as a vector here for
a moment any set of motions acts as a
superposition of each contributing mode
now each mode has a mode shape to it
which I'm going to call you and up here
I'll put a superscript for what mode it
is the first mode times its
time-dependent behavior and this is
called what they call in textbooks these
are called the natural coordinates we'll
see what those are in a second so mode
shape one this is the time dependent and
amplitude part that says how much the
contribution of mode one is
this motion and what its time dependence
is this is and then you'd have mode
two's contribution q2 and this goes out
to the enth modes contribution qn of T
and that's the proposition that you can
represent the total response of the
system as a superposition of the
response of each of the natural modes of
the system and if it's an N degree of
freedom system there be n natural modes
so
now something I didn't say here's this
is all this all assumes that the system
vibrates so this is this is all in the
discussion of things that exhibit
vibratory motion so this is all should
see here of vibrating systems
so this is kind of a long and cumbersome
way of writing this out so if you notice
each one of these is the mode shape
vector and if I put them together in a
matrix it would look just side by side
here's a u one over to you in and
multiply it by this vector q1 of T down
to Q n that's the same statement but
said in a much more compact way so the
statement is modal expansion theorem
basically says the vector of these are
your generalized coordinates which we've
been using all term long these are the
generalized coordinates that you choose
to derive the equations of motion around
the vector of generalized coordinates
can be written as u Q and these are
often called the modal coordinates or
sometimes called the natural coordinates
so if we can say that X is U Q then X
dot you take the derivative of each one
of those expressions you'll find that
going to be u Q dot and X double dot
equals u Q double dot because these are
just constants the mode shape vectors
are just a fixed set of numbers that
represent the mode shapes of the system
now just to think maybe it's a good time
to do this you grab one end so this is a
and it's hard to see black against black
my apologies for that but so this is a
guitar string or you know any stringed
instrument or in fact any long slender
thing under tension will vibrate and it
has I do this carefully that's called
the first mode of vibration and that's
when you pluck your guitar string or
violin in the middle you mostly hear
that and but at twice the frequency if I
can get it going here there's a second
mode of vibration and for a taut string
it's it happens to be it twice the
frequency of the first and if I my hand
is well calibrated it may be easier to
look longer I get this going right
there's a third mode
okay so each that's what we that's what
we're calling Oh what I meant to say
when I was doing this is these shapes
for the vibrating string that second
mode shape happens to be one full sine
wave in the mode shape has the form sine
n PI x over L where L is the length of
the string ends the mode number so first
mode second mode is this when NS to
first mode and is one n mode or
something hi
you know you get higher modes like that
so these are the mode shapes for a
vibrating string so that's and this
that's good for now this L this two
degree of freedom system with the to
lump masses and it's going to show up
there yeah okay this is basically two
lumped masses and we idealize the
springs as being massless but it's a
pretty good approximation this has two
modes of vibration and professor Gossard
made these neat little things that can
make it so now what you've been I'm
going to come back to this but there's
mode one and the mode shape is as this
goes down one unit that goes down about
two two times as much I give you the
exact numbers in a minute and the other
mode shape of the system I do the right
in if I give it the right initial we're
going to talk about this today and why
this happens but if I give it the right
initial conditions I can make it vibrate
only in the second mode shape and so
it's now deflected with the right
conditions so that it'll respond only in
second mode this mass goes up and down a
lot that mass goes up and down little
opposite to it actually the frequency is
different from the first but if this is
moving one unit then this down here is
moving minus 0.3 or something like that
and that ratio is constant and that's
the called the mode
so if you just pick one of them and say
let its motion be one then all of the
other masses in the system will move in
a particular ratio to the motion of that
one that you arbitrarily set to one so
this will mean by mode shapes and their
natural frequencies there's the natural
frequency associated with that first
mode and we can solve these things
mathematically and we've been doing that
a little a little bit in the last couple
of lectures all right so this is the
relationship between these things the
generalized coordinates and the modal
coordinates and we now need to see how
we are going to use these
so in general we have our equations of
motion and I'm going to substitute for
xx dot and X double dot these so
and pre multiplied by u transpose where
the transpose of a matrix you just take
the column first column make of the
first row second column make it the
second row so if I plug in these up here
I get em u Q leave some space here we're
going to pre multiply in a second plus C
u q dot plus K u Q equals the external
exciting forces now I'm going to pre
multiply by u transpose okay
now a remarkable thing happens it
happens that if you take when you cook
when you do this calculation when you
multiply this matrix times that one row
at a time so this has this has vectors
in it one through n I'm going to pick
vector R the Arth one I take that our
vector and multiply it one at a time by
row by row by row then I get a new
vector the results which I'm going to
multiply by this so if I'm going to sit
up but I'm going to pick out one of the
vectors multiply through times one of
the rows here which is all the when you
transpose them the rows are now the
vectors so I'm going to pick if I do the
calculation plus my right piece of paper
here
so I just pulled this pull out one of
these come one of the calculations that
you end up doing if you do this whole
triple matrix multiplication there will
you need to know the following fact so
if we're mode the mode s transpose
that's one of the rows out of here times
M times one of the columns the Arth one
from here and I do this calculation this
is 0 for R not equal to s with that
statement says is the only nonzero
result from this is there is when you
multiply when you take the Arth column
from here and you use the R 0 from here
all the other combinations are this
thing go to 0 and the net result of that
is that this implies that you transpose
M you always equals to a diagonal vector
which I'll call this like that sometimes
a mass matrix is diagonal start with but
even if it isn't you do this calculation
it will produce a diagonal matrix and
that's because this is this these
multiplications are always 0 it less R
is the same as s and the same is true
for you transpose K you will give you a
K matrix that is diagonal and you know
normally when the stiffness matrix we've
come up with they've generally not been
they've generally been full matrices
often times but you do UK UK you you
will get diagonal stiffness matrix
and problem look there the little
problem comes because you transpose see
you well sometimes this one is diagonal
only for ideal conditions of damping so
we're going to have that's something you
just have to address
so only for ideal conditions and that's
just something you have to deal with so
this why is this why is this gut you
know wise there's a special wonderful
thing the natural modes of a system this
one is a two degree freedom system form
a complete and independent set of
vectors and in this case of this two
degree freedom system I can pick any any
allow any kinematically allowable
position like this stationary static is
a static is one of the solutions right
to this two degree freedom system so any
any possible allowable position of these
two things static are moving can be
described by a linear combination of the
mode shapes of the system a weighted sum
of the mode shapes of the system and
that's all it takes so this one has two
mode shapes you know one that looks kind
of like that one that looks like this
one's going down this one's going up
there are particular ratios and I can
take a weighted amount of that first
mode so much of it and a weighted amount
of the second mode and add them together
and describe any possible position of
the system the same thing is true of
that string it has mode shapes that are
sine ways but they sine 1 PI X by 2 pi X
over L and so forth any possible linear
in any possible allowable shape of that
guitar string can be made up of a
weighted sum of the mode shapes of the
system
and moreover the mode shapes the reason
this works
because because the mode shapes are
orthogonal to one another now you know
that if you take two sine waves like
that string and you and you take sine
first mode sine PI x over L and second
mode say sine 2 pi X over L and you
multiply them together and integrate
from 0 to L what you get you'll always
get zero if the two signs are if they're
full wave lengths they go to nodes at
the end you will always get 0 if the
wave lengths are different always right
that's a statement of orthogonal T of
sine functions same thing is true of
these simple vectors there are thuggin
all to one another such that if you do
this multiplication you transpose mu you
only get contributions when you are
using mode R transpose M mode R you only
get a contribution of each of those that
gives you the diagonals the same is true
when you do u transpose K u because of
orthogonality you only get a diagonal
matrix at the end and under the right
conditions u transpose Cu gives you a
diagonal matrix so what's that good for
well here was the set of equations that
we get when we make that substitution
this is going to give us a diagonal mass
matrix times Q double dot plus when
conditions are right a diagonal damping
matrix times Q dot plus a diagonal
stiffness matrix times Q equals u
transpose F which so vector times a
matrix gives you back a vector which we
call capital Q it's a function of time
and this is called the modal force but
if you look carefully at these if I pick
the Arth one mode mode are out of this
whole thing so the or R if I just pick
any mode out of this and part of this
vector and complete this multiplication
I will find that I get an M R which is
the Arth entry here and now to I'm going
to refer to these as the modal masses
and I'll write them with capitals and I
get a subscript to tell you what the
mode is this is a number this is the
modal massed Ramotar this gives me an
equation it looks like m RQ r double dot
plus CR q r dot plus K R u R equals Q R
of T and what does that remind you of
that we've done a lot of work with how
many degree of freedom system
it looks that's the equation of motion a
generic equation of motion of a single
degree freedom oscillator and you know
how to calculate the response to initial
conditions for that you know how to
calculate the steady-state response for
that when you have a harmonic input
right when I said at the beginning that
would be again in the beginning of the
discussion about vibration is it sorry
important to understand the single
degree of freedom oscillator because it
gives you it'll give you insight as to
the behavior of complicated multiple
degree freedom systems and here's here's
the proof of this any this is now n
uncoupled single degree of freedom
systems this is n independent single one
degree of freedom systems which you can
solve one at a time
now lots of times a vibrating system a
complicated one might be this thing I
hit this it's vibrating and actually
it's pretty much vibrating at a single
frequency and are there any once I've
hit it
are there any external forces driving it
so what kind of response are you seeing
response to initial conditions right now
in general each one of the natural modes
of a system has a different natural
frequency right so if I hit this thing
and I look at it you know it really I
can just see it wiggling back and forth
and basically at one frequency so if you
wanted to come up with a simple model of
this system how many natural modes do
you think you'd have to include to
describe the motion of this system one
now is that a lot easier than having to
do the full general equation of motion
for all the possible modes that this
thing has and during talk a lot right
you have to deal with the equation of
motion of a single degree freedom system
to describe this and that's the real
point you know they built the Hancock
building across the river 35 years ago
was losing Windows like crazy it was
brand new building and the windows 1 the
window get about 40 miles an hour other
windows started falling out 60 stories
high 60 61 stories high and the wind was
blowing where do you suppose the windows
fall out what part of the building huh I
mean you'd think the one that wind is
blowing it gets stronger as it goes up
is probably blown out the wind is at the
top right but the wind isn't breaking as
you as a time went by every time they
window would break that would replace
this five foot by nine foot sheet of
glass with a piece of plywood and so you
got the statistical sampling after a
while of where the breakage was so you
had no windows broken at the top and a
few as you got further down and more
and lots of them broken out at the
bottom it turns out that that building
was vibrating in its boast mostly in its
first bending mode it was going back and
forth like this also have navitor gional
mode search torsional mode was kind of
twisting around the base like that so in
fact this motion the moment when you get
about 40 miles an hour I was building a
start rocking and rolling mostly like
this with a little of this thrown in
okay and but you can basically model a
complicated building that has millions
of possible natural modes in it by one
or possibly two single degree freedom
oscillators so that's the power modal
analysis but I think the real power of
understanding that you can do this is
that it gives you this immediate insight
as to what might be going on in
something so I look at this I don't see
a complicated thing that I have to model
with a big finite element model I see
something is vibrating at one frequency
and I can I know it has a it'll decay
it'll have damping and have a natural
frequency and I get a median insight as
to its behavior by knowing this okay and
that's the real reason why I wanted to
show this to you so today we I won't
will do these are two things to play two
directions we can go with this one is to
talk about response to initial
conditions and the other is to talk
about the response to force excitation
so let's we're going to begin by doing
response to ICS okay and then we'll move
on probably next time and talk about
response to harmonic excitations and B
so before and we're going to use that as
the example before I go there once we
have broken the system down and analyzed
it this way how do we get back to the
motion of the system in our generalized
coordinates which are the ones we're
comfortable with because I don't know
how to take word
ruler and go measure yes you measured
this natural coordinate so somehow I
have to get back to putting into real
physical measurements that I know how
that I can relate to well that's easy
because it's where did we start with
this we started by saying this whole
thing began right here and so at the end
you week we just come back and say oh
well X here our generalized coordinates
is this summation of the mode shapes you
I hear some summed over I of Q I of T
now the reason I wrote it here is the
summation is it to you just to remind
you that you do this
that's the beauty of this thing is you
only have to do it over the modes that
matter or so if you've decided to
approximate the motion of this
complicated complicated system by just a
couple of modal contributions because
you know they're the important ones this
this is a pretty short summation this is
how you get back to your original modal
coordinates let's take a modal amplitude
multiply it by the mode shape and when
you do that it says you know this turns
out to be say some a sine Omega T when
you multiply it by the mode shape it
basically tells you how much each
generalized coordinate gets of the
motion the mode shape distributes the
answer out proportionally in the correct
amount so this is how you get back to
the original so let's think about that
system and we'll do an initial
conditions kind of problem so I think
professor Gossard you I think in class
you sort of figured out what the
approximate k's and m's and things were
for that system so I actually took it
apart weighed it measured some natural
frequencies and I've come up with a
pretty good model it released pretty
good set of numbers characterizing this
two degree freedom system
so C 1 K 1 M 1 K 2 C 2 X 1 X 2 so these
are my generalized coordinates measured
probably from what position static
equilibrium right so I don't even mess
with gravity in this measured from
static equilibrium and to try to help
keep things understandable track I've
right I tried to write the parameters of
the system as lowercase K 1 sk 2 sk 3 s
because i want to write
modal stiffness for mode 1 as a capital
k 1 so try to be consistent about that
and notice where I put the dampers in
the system that's because most of the
damping in this thing comes from the
upper mass rubs against the stationary
object and the lower which is slightly a
bar here the lower mass rubs against the
stationary object so it's as if I'm
going to model that as a dashpot between
each mass and the fixed reference frame
because then the bar doesn't move so
it's an approximate model of the damping
and so if we do our sum of forces on
each of these masses just do Newton's
law on the mass we can come up with it
our two equations motion we get two
equations of motion and let's see I
think I'll give you some information
here first m1
so those and I really don't know the
damping but we can get that by counting
how many cycles it takes to decay and so
forth so that's basically what I come
into this problem knowing and I'm going
to write my equations of motion and in
matrix form so it's going to end up
looking like m 1 now notice the damping
in this one the damping force is only
proportionate it'll be c1 x1 dot had
nothing doesn't involve the motion of
the other object and this one the
damping force only involves the second
motion so this have this what happens
look like a c10 c2 stiffness matrix
let's k1 plus k2 minus k2 minus k2 and
k2 X 1 X 2 and for no external forces it
starts off this one is a as note stir
and nothing on the right-hand side to
equal to zero so there's my equations of
motion and you know if you multiply this
out you get two equations and each one
would be as a result that you get by
applying Newton's law to mass 1 and
Newton's a lot of mass 2 but you've
we've done that enough times I'm not
going to go through that that part of it
ok
and put it in real numbers
that's our mass matrix
I don't know this stiffness matrix
so this is my K matrix here and
stiffness matrices they're always
symmetric damping me that that although
this one happen to be diagonal you'll
find that mass matrices and even the
damping matrices for our linear systems
are symmetric so here's your stiffness
matrix here's my mass matrix okay so now
I want to do and also this case here's
my damping matrix but I'll leave that
because it's the one that's a little bit
troublesome so what do I need to do to
this to carry out my modal analysis so I
need to go find the results of computing
u transpose M + u u + u transpose K u
and let's see what we get so we need to
know a couple of things about this
system we need to know natural
frequencies and mode shapes so if we
have this mass matrix and we have the
stiffness matrix then we know we can
cast this we want the undamped natural
frequencies and our mode shapes
and we know that we can transform the
equation that we have the equations of
motion into an algebraic problem where
we solve for the natural frequencies and
mode shapes so we have just a kind of we
remind you really quickly of that
remember our equations look like this
undamped and you assume that X is some
form U in fact e to the I Omega T plug
it in you get minus Omega squared M plus
K u e to the I Omega T equals 0 and this
now is your algebraic problem either
this unknown set of amplitudes is 0 with
these two going to turn out to be the
mode shapes and they're not generally
zero so that means this has to be 0 that
means we know the determinant of this
matrix and that'll give you the net in
this case the two natural frequencies
this gives you the Omega ends of the
system mega n Squared's it's what you
solve for ok and then you go back and
you get the the mode shapes out of it
and but this you can do on the computer
too you can either crank out the court
this gives you for a two degree freedom
system this gives you a quadratic in
omega squared you solve it plug it back
in and get the mode shapes I'm not going
to take the time to do that today
because I want to do emphasize the modal
analysis part so I'll give you the
answers
oh yeah
so you get a mega one it's five point
six five four six and I seem to be
keeping a lot of a lot of significant
digits and there's a reason for that one
of the reasons you need in both mode
shapes and natural frequencies you need
to carry a lot of significant digits or
modal analysis doesn't work or at least
you don't get to clean results you
expect if you're sloppy about the number
of significant digits and you compute u
transpose mu then the off diagonal terms
won't quite go to zero that's just
because you're not carrying enough
precision okay now that's the two
natural frequencies and now the U matrix
the mode shapes for this system that
goes with that u comes out to be 1.0 and
to point to 6 6 7 that's mode I'll do
this to help you the columns are the
mode shapes that's the first mode shape
the second mode shape is 1 and minus 0.2
2 3 6 so that's your mode so those are
the mode shapes for the first and second
mode that go with these two natural
frequencies so that's for this system
the top one moves one unit the bottom
one moves to point two seven times that
the same direction positive positive the
upper one moves one unit the bottom one
moves the opposite direction that's the
minus sign squiggling to a phase angle
of 180 degrees minus 22 percent of the
amount that the upper one moves so first
one moves one unit the bottom one moves
2.2 times that and in the second mode
which is much harder to get going
it's the only way I can do it is to do
it the way professor Gossard intended
here one you ended up and down - point
two two three six going the opposite way
so those are our mode shapes these are
the natural frequencies I calculated
this one and measured it a stopwatch
this one I can do watching it with a
stopwatch and I came within less better
than 1% they're getting the same number
okay
so I carry I want my modal mass matrix I
carry out this calculation and for this
system remember it's going to give me
back a diagonal matrix looking like this
and in fact the numbers are three point
five five six two zero zero and point
three five zero eight and when I can
calculate u transpose K u gives me a
diagonal stiffness matrix and I get the
numbers one one three point seven one
and zero zero one zero nine point eight
three nine
that's my diagonal diagonalized
stiffness matrix now something had
better be true I'm saying that this
isn't it this is now going to give me my
two independent single degree freedom
equations of motion right so I'm looking
for
so what I'm seeking here I want to get
two equations one that looks like M 1 Q
1 double dot plus C 1 Q 1 dot plus K 1 Q
1 equals 0 for no external force that's
one of the equations I'm after and the
other one look like M 2 Q 2 double dot
plus C 2 Q 2 dot K 2 Q 2 now one way to
check that you've gotten the right thing
is now these are independent two
independent single degree freedom
systems what's the natural frequency of
this system
mm oh yeah actually I heard somebody say
square root of K 1 over m 1 that had
better be true but what numerically
what's the number what did it better be
it better be the Omega 1 of the system
right and so a check that you can
perform is list is to check to see if
the Omega 1 squared equals K 1 over m 1
just you found two numbers you've got up
here k 1 is 113 point 7 m 1 is 3 point 5
5 take K 1 over m 1 and take its square
root so k 1 over m 1 that's about 30
something square root of 30 something is
a little less than 6 Omega 1 is 5 point
6 5 and the same thing Omega 2 had
better be equal to the square root of K
2 over m 2 so one of the things you can
always do and you do your modal analysis
you do your calculations that you
transpose mu u transpose K u if you
calculate the ratios of each one of
these things you can go back and check
they can see the natural frequencies are
the ones that you started with if you
have if they are not then you've messed
up in your arithmetic so now we've got
our 2 intended equations and the natural
frequencies check out but we haven't we
still have a couple of things to deal
with we have to figure out how to
calculate the initial conditions and we
have to figure out how to deal with
damping let's do initial what I see is
first
so those of you who are here last time I
ended kind of right at the end we kind
of worked our way through figuring out
the initial conditions for a two degree
freedom system doing it the hard way end
up with four equations and four unknowns
for the a1 a2 fee one fee to remember
that I mean it's really painful there's
a this is this is incredibly easier
we're going to do the same thing but
extremely easily so I would never go
myself but given the choice of grinding
out all those phase angles and
amplitudes I buy in simultaneous
equations I'd do the following how if I
generally now I know the initial
conditions are going to be specified not
in Q coordinates but into what
coordinate system the original
generalized coordinates right you know
you're going to exit this one the
general if I'm going to set initial
conditions here I'm not going to say q1
is equal to something I'm going to say
I'm going to put this one down one unit
and this one down two units and let go
this is in x1 and x2 coordinates but the
beautiful thing here is that we know
that x equals u Q so if I know the
initial conditions on I'll call it X
naught here if I know the initial
collections of the system they're going
to be u times the initial value of the
initial values of Q and if I know a
vector of initial velocities at time 0
they're going to be u Q 0 dot so if I
told you values of X naught and I and
you know that this equation is true what
we need is Q the Q knots we need the
initial conditions in in a modal
coordinates in order to finish this
problem how would you get if I told you
this how do you solve for that
just a little in Italy rounds over here
yeah multiply by u inverse right okay so
this implies that Q not there I'll be
right it out a little more fully here so
if I do u inverse X naught that's going
to be equal to u inverse u q naught u
inverse times u gives you 1 basically
right and so I have just if I do u
inverse X naught I get Q naught that's
always do it yeah and I sees a problem
again I'm leaving it I'm leaving it to
the end we're going to deal with it as
the last step and if I have initial
velocities u inverse times X initial
velocities vector I get the initial
velocities vector in the natural
coordinates so that's how simple it is
to get the initial conditions in modal
coordinates
and we're going to do a numerical
example in second here we're looking for
we're seeking a solution of the form to
do initial to do response to initial
conditions receipt equations the we know
a write for a single degree freedom
system response to initial conditions so
we know that for a single degree of
freedom system X of T this is for s do
f-4s do F system here X of T we've
worked out before is equal to some eetu
the minus Zeta Omega n T this is just a
transient decay problem of X naught
cosine Omega DT plus V naught plus Zeta
Omega n X naught all over Omega D sine
Omega DT we know that that's what the
response of a single degree freedom
system looks like two initial conditions
X naught and V naught and for light
damping for small damping you can often
usually even ignore this term so it's
just it's even simpler this term is
usually small compared to them alright
smart this term contribution from X
naught is small compared to this term so
it's basically dominated by an X naught
cosine and a V naught over Omega D sine
but that's the we know that's the exact
response to for a single degree of
freedom system to initial
so just by analogy to that we're looking
for for mode 1 in modal coordinates it's
going to look exactly the same way
e to the minus theta Omega n T Q naught
cosine Omega 1 D is Omega DT plus Q
naught dot plus is Zeta 1 Omega 1 Q
naught I guess I need to do Q 1 not like
that this is the first modes equation
Zeta 1 and I'll call this Omega 1 but
now they get multiple degree freedom
systems you've got to keep track of what
mode you're talking about mode one
damping ratio mode one natural frequency
mode one initial displacement mode one
initial velocity mode one Omega 1 D like
that and mode 2 is going to be exactly
analogous Q 2 equals and it's exactly
similar except you put an update it with
a 2 instead of a 1 if you plug in the
initial you've over here have found the
initial values for Q 1 and 1 naught and
Q 2 naught and Q 1 dot naught and so
forth you found the initial values that
plug into that equation by just doing
this and once we have this then we can
go back to saying how do you get to the
get back to the final answer
well you just multiply the result for Q
times the mode shape and add them up and
you have the answer but we still have to
deal with the damping problem
I'm going to do that one next but I see
a bunch of hands like some puzzled look
so it means it's a good time to stop and
talk for a second yeah alright okay
we're here decide I'll be signing with
you
yeah what about why do we use it oh you
don't lose it I was saying it see this
is this bit it's like that these are two
pieces that behave like sign and this
see this one depends on initial
displacement but it's multiplied by the
damping ratio the damping ratio for
things that are interesting is usually
pretty small so here you have a term
that's X naught cosine Omega one damped
and here you have a contribution that's
X naught small times X naught sine of
negative one negative one damp so you
multiply it the same their house for
operating the same frequency two terms
at the same frequency add them together
it's like a cosine Omega t minus some
phase angle if this little term is small
that phase angle is almost zero
cosine X naught cosine plus something X
naught sine it gives you sine term that
is shifted a little bit and it's that
magnitude is different by this little
amount I'm just saying often times this
is small but if you don't want to make
that approximation just carry it along
just do it mm-hmm oh no and I'm nothing
wrong I'm just saying you can take you
can throw out this piece usually and it
simply it makes I keep in my mind
vibrate me safe kind of vibration
engineering is full of lots of
approximations because it's very hard to
get oftentimes to get detailed
quantitative numbers on exactly
everything you need to know so I carry
around little approximations that I know
is the way the world mostly behaves the
way the world mostly behaves for a
single degree of freedom system is the
response to initial conditions looks
like this and this initial value here is
always approximately X naught and this
initial slope here is always
approximately till the slope is V naught
that's the slope now it turns out that
this thing is shifted just it's shifted
just slightly why because of this term
okay but I honest Lu truth it almost
really directly matters so as a
vibration engineer I oftentimes gistic I
just remember I have an X dot cosine I
have a V naught over mega D sine and the
whole thing decays like that but if
you're like to be mathematically precise
you carry along that little bit yeah you
know I could lose a sine
oh wait a minute I just left it out oh
you guys well I'm glad you're awake this
is good now how's that ah good now I
know who I had so many puzzle because it
looks anybody have a different question
just anything now about this whole modal
analysis thing because then we have to
deal with this awkward part that has to
do with the damping and I got to finish
on time okay
the alright so damping I've gotten this
far what I need is I need estimates for
the for the damping for mode 1 and
damping for mode 2 right
so the problem is that you t see you
does not always equal some nice
diagonalized matrix you sometimes get
these are not always zero okay it just
the orthogonality principle just doesn't
apply to the damping terms just doesn't
and but isn't the egg but this actually
doesn't hurt you a lot you just got to
know that this is going to be a problem
and when the systems are lightly damped
the approximation even if you're the
true damping in the system gives you
some nonzero elements here the the
first-order behavior the system is
basically going to be you can just
ignore the off diagonal elements what
practical consequence do you think it
has if these if you have some actual
nonzero numbers here go back and look at
the equations that you're trying to
derive it's these were the equations
that we're trying to come up with and we
wanted them to be in individual single
degree freedom systems but if this has
off nonzero off diagonal terms you're
going to find popping up in this single
degree freedom equation another term
that couples it through damping to the
other modes it provides a little bit of
coupling to the other two other modes
they can talk to one another
alright and what that means is if I just
may be a good time to do the
demonstration
how do I want to say this
if the initial displacement of the
system is in the shape of one of the
natural modes so if this is some you
this is exactly shaped like mode R so
this looks like the you are vector when
I multiply it by this in what I do when
I multiply when I carry out this
multiplication what do you think will
happen if this is shape this is shaped
like mode are because of our thuggin
ality when I do u inverse which is all
about the mode shapes information and
the mode shapes are or these orthogonal
set of and independent orthogonal
vectors if this is exactly one mode and
I do u inverse times that I will get
zero over here on the right hand side
for every mode except the bowed that
that shape like so if this is shaped
like a particular mode then over here
all of the modal initial conditions are
0 except that mode that means if I set
this it give its initial conditions are
equal to the shape exactly of mode 1 it
only responds in mode 1 and if I give it
put it give it initial conditions that
are exactly equal to shape like that of
mode 2 then it only responds in mode 2
and if I give it anything else like I
move just the top one but not the bottom
and let it go then there's that one's ID
you have it or do the other one that
went at too much at one not the other I
hold this one here's its reference I can
hold it right there and I'm going to
give this one a unit deflection and let
go now you see again some of both
all right so
if when I do this first one say first
mode I could sit here and measure how
many cycles it takes to decay halfway
and estimate the damping ratio for that
mode it's only moving in this mode I can
estimate it I could estimate its damping
directly for that mode and gets a 2-1
you agree okay and if I did the same
thing with mode 2 it's too fast for me
to make mice to catch it with a
stopwatch but I could measure its
damping and as it decays I could get an
estimate for Zeta tube for the damping
ratio for mode 2 all right all right
that somehow I have to get damping ratio
for mode 1 Zeta 1 and damping ratio for
mode 2 Zeta 2 I have to somehow get it
out of this I have to model it somehow
with these stamping coefficients that
come from computing this u transpose Cu
ok so I'm going to just as I'm going to
show you a kind of damping called
Rayleigh damping ok Lord Rayleigh who
did lots of things in science that
you've probably run into proposed that
if you let the damping if you model your
damping the C matrix as this is just now
the system damping matrix that you start
with as some alpha times the mass matrix
plus beta times the stiffness matrix
these are now the original ones of your
in your generalized coordinates is your
mass and stiffness matrices if you model
if you say I'm going to approximate my
damping model like this then
I want to compute u transpose Cu I'm
going to get alpha u transpose mu plus
beta u transpose ke u but we know that
this gives you the diagonalized mass
matrix and this known as the modal mass
matrix this gives you the diagonalize
stiffness matrix and so this damping
model this says this is guaranteed to
give you a diagonalized damping matrix
which we'll call somehow some capital C
1 0 0 C 2 right and it's going to be
alpha times the modal mass matrix plus a
beta times the modal stiffness matrix
and these alphas and betas you adjust
they're just parameters you adjust to
get the amount of damping you need ok so
for a two degree of freedom system
see one here is alpha M 1 plus beta M
beta k 2 k 1 k 1 excuse me
modal mass alpha times the modal mass
plus beta times the modal stiffness
that's what you get for the first one at
C 2 is alpha M 2 plus beta k 2 ok and
the alphas and betas give you two free
parameters you can play with and for a
two degree freedom system I can
manipulate alpha and beta to get the
damping that I measure and I and I've
forced my equations of motion to
uncouple now mother nature may say the
you know you know Vandiver they don't
uncouple and there's going to be a
little crosstalk between them but I say
you have it to first order I under
pretty good model of the system so let's
do that in this case let's maybe it is
to keep it I've got numbers here so let
me find my notes I don't get completely
lost here
so I don't want to just pick one for now
I'm going to model my damping with just
beta k
beta times my diagonalize stiffness
matrix let's see let's see what happens
here
so that says my modal damping is going
to be sum for mode 1 with speed beta k1
now what's damping ratio Zeta 1 equals
for a single degree of freedom system is
the damping constant for the system over
2 Omega 1 m1 but that's going to be beta
k1 over 2 Omega 1 M 1 but M 1 over K 1
is Omega 1 squared so I get an Omega 1
squared in the numerator beta Omega 1
squared over 2 Omega 1 remember the K
over the M give me the Omega 1 squared
so the MS are gone and cancel one of
these this gives me beta Omega 1 over 2
so this now gives me a way of I can fit
one of the damping's
I can get exactly what I want say for
mode 1 if I pick beta to be the right
number okay so in this case I actually
did some numbers
pardon can't hear no k1 over m 1 is
omega 1 squared Omega 1 squared takes
care of the M 1 I get rid of one of the
Omega ones I'm left with this ok ok so
what if so let's just let beta equals
0.01 and if you let beta equal to 0.01
then Zeta 1 equals 0.01 Omega 1 over 2
we know Omega 1 is 5 point 6 5 this when
you work it out then gives you a number
of point zero two eight three about
three percent and that would model that
would say that this system when it
vibrates in mode one is going to damp
out up to 50 percent about three cycles
not bad approximations I'm just guessing
about what it is that's a reasonable
amount of damping for mode 1 now the
problem is when I only use just beta K
as my model now I'm stuck with whatever
happens for mode 2 once I picked beta
because Zeta 2 is going to be beta Omega
2 over 2 and Omega 2 is quite a bit
larger so that makes I'm stuck with a
greater value for the second mode in
this case it's 0 8 8 5 so if I just pick
a one parameter model for my damping I'm
I can make one perfect I can match it
perfectly but then I'm stuck with
whatever the other one is so I did this
because I could do it simply with 1 but
if I'd kept the full-bottle a 2
parameter model I could actually with
manipulating both alpha and beta I could
actually model get both of the 2
measured damping exactly right but if I
have an N degree if I have three degree
of freedom system I only have two
parameters I can fit to the damping
ratios but then I'm going to be stuck
with whatever it gives me for the
but oftentimes it's just one mode you
really care about it it's the problem
mode you're at its natural frequency its
right going like crazy initial
conditions make it vibrate a lot in that
mode but this is what Rayleigh damping
allows you to do it guarantees you that
you will have a diagonals that
diagonalized set of equations of motion
and it gives you two parameters you can
play with to fit the dancing model
however you want once you have damping
now you have the complete solution for
decay from initial conditions there's
your two model you can solve for q1
transit decay given initial conditions
you can solve for Q to transient K of
the second mode and then to get back to
the initial to the response in terms of
your modal coordinates you just add the
two together got some numbers here which
are just instructive lets you inverse in
order to get these initial conditions
you've got to know u inverse do we know
you
I gave us u here's our mode shape set of
mode shape vectors and I'm run out of
boards
so we have the you matrix we need u
inverse so u inverse for this problem
and we're going to quickly do some
examples let's let V the V knots be 0 no
initial conditions on velocities and
let's do X naught the initial
displacements be 1 and 0 so the 1 and 0
we're saying is the bottom ones it
doesn't move unit deflection here let go
what do you what are you going to get
for the initial conditions X naught
equals 1 and 0 well that implies that
the Q's are going to be u inverse X
naught so by the way this if this is
true this implies that all Q dot initial
conditions equal 0 right no initial cut
velocities in generalized coordinates no
initial velocities in modal coordinates
but here we have but we are going to
have an initial deflection and if I want
to multiply want to then compute u
inverse X naught and see what I get and
what I get back when I do this one is
point zero eight nine eight and point
nine 102
this is q1 not q2 so for that case it
says I'm going to get point oh eight or
0.09 q1 equal to q1 and point nine have
q2 and my I go back over here to my
transient decay there's no velocity so
it's basically going to look like q1 q1
naught cosine Omega DT D to the minus 8
Omega T decaying cosine but for mode 1
its initial amplitudes you know less
than point 1 and mode 2 it's got a lot
of mode 2 so it is what happens so will
unit deflection here in fact it's mostly
mode 2 and if I just quickly I'll do one
other X naught is 0 1 that implies the q
q naught that you get from that is 0.40
1 6 and minus point 4 0 1 6 so as you
get about equal amounts so that's this
one I don't move this one but I give
this one a unit deflection let go in
about equal amounts of each one and of
course I've told you the answer to this
one is if I let X equal mode ones mode
shape one and two point two six six that
implies that Q 1 equals 1 and Q 2 when
you multiply it out is zero so if I
dafuq it in the shape of mode 1 and I do
u inverse X naught I will get back a 0
and 1 and if I make this the shape of
mode 2 I will get back 0 for mode 1 and
1/4
so that will that's the run out of time
but that's your intro to modal analysis
so I think it's conceptually powerful
oh is this 1.08 okay I may have written
that down
yeah I'll Chad double-check that but yep
question beta because I wanted to get
done by the end of the 60 million I 80
minutes I could have put both of them in
nip Y elated both parameters is two
equations two unknowns to target values
of damping I'd find an alpha and a beta
it would make both work exactly right it
actually just this one model is pretty
good for this case the damping for
second load is greater than the first
mode this happens to be this bottles not
bad yeah
you